khabbach 9 7 4 en plein coeur de la
capitale
pari gagné pour l'antenne de paris du
conseil départemental de la réunion qui
réunit un plateau à la hauteur de la
richesse musicale réunionnaise
le maloya c'est une musique très
important pour nous c'est une musique
est reconnu dans le monde entier et
c'est une musique qui rassemble ans qui
rassemble les gens se soient des gens de
l'outre-mer où les gens la métropole
c'est toute une équipe qui s'est
mobilisée au faire de cette
manifestation une réussite notamment
avec l'objectif de promouvoir et de
valoriser notre identité culturelle une
identité sous toutes ses formes
jean jérôme le street artiste parisien
et réunionnais réalise une performance
en direct la réunion et la fête de la
musique sont très importantes pour la
culture réunionnaise pour représenter la
culture réunionnaise sur la métropole
une foule de 5000 personnes attendues
sur la place du palais royal
quelques drapeaux de lille qui flottent
et sur scène
les danseuses de métissage et le kayamb
déroulèrent du groupe racine mêlée pour
réchauffer l'ambiance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et cela
tous les styles se succèdent pour tous
les goûts visiblement tous les âges
soleil à isner dia tsy cas maroni pour
tous ses ambassadeurs de la musique
réunionnaise le moment est rare et
rempli d'émotions et le lieu choisi
entre le louvre et le ministère de la
culture donne une certaine fierté
nous sommes très fiers de représenter la
réunion sur paris et de montrer aux
parisiens le style de la réunion de
séga-maloya c'est un grand jour de
mélodies de rassemblement de partage de
musique et ben c'est un honneur de
pouvoir jouer à paris c'est un grand
plaisir déjà pour faire découvrir une
musique et pour donner la vibration de
la réunion et la chaleur de la réunion
ce sont 20 super ambiance
les gens ont répondu chaleureusement à
l'invitation
la réunion représente on est bien d'être
là j'espère que ça va bouillonner encore
et encore pour se sent bouillonner
vibrer dont c'est le rendez vous de la
fête de la musique à paris a tenu ses
promesses
rassembler un public de tous horizons et
vivre une soirée intense à l'image de la
réunion
la quête de la musique c'est qu'on se
renier tous et on découvre et les
musiques de tous les coins du monde
merci au département des réunions par
mois groupe et tout le monde
la reine ou neuf cadres présenta mariman
fête de la musique
la police ya les malgaches shell tous
les pays décident de le saint siège
on est tous réunis ce soir
la fête de la musique avec la réunion
c'est la meilleure solution
qui payera voix mais on n'est pas à la
réunion
les rythmes du maloya se sont perdus
loin dans la nuit ce soir paris s'est
endormi à plusieurs milliers de
kilomètres
quelque part dans l'océan indien